[音楽]
[拍手]
5年前
彼がなかった僕はポップも法律といい英語伝教皇として英語で日記を書くことを決め
ました
参考書も江川スクールも語学留学についてません
今日は英語に気が付人生を変えたと思います
今あの会場にも英語が話せるようになりたいとかをたくさんいると思います
細江さん任せ
でも
1年間の語学留学の平均費用って300万円で言われているんですよ
から僕は
たくさんバイトしました絶対に留学しってったのかな
絶対にお金を止めて英語が話せるようになりたい
3倍としよう
甘い時
以前になんです
慣れないけど
でも
英語を話した人か一番初めにある努力が
お金を貯めれにあるの底おかしいんじゃないよ
毎日本当に3つぐらいかけましてバイトしてるんですけどこれが細いからちゃい
目である英語が話せるに直結する感じがなかった
僕はすごくショー的なんですけどこんなことを考え頃から
スタートしました
自分はなんで英語が話せるようになりたいんだっけ
汗レオナルドしたらどのくらいの英語力が必要なんだっけ
弁狭窄ても考え方なんですけどこういうところ
考えるところからこの英語勉強をスタートしですね
そして
思います
そうそ英語がの線って何だ
英語が話せるようになりたい人内になりたかったんですけど
英語が話せるよう話せる人が
何を指すのかがわかってなかったですね
こんな曖昧な方へでこれ語を話すようになる人になれるわけじゃないと思う
なので
まずは英語が話せるの定義を決める
ここから始めをてますかこれが元の
英語勉強法
発端です
19惨劇2013年の7月13日ですね
この日僕の中の英語が話せる兵が決まりました
実は15歳からギターを始めて
フェンスというバンドのボーカル集まりミュージシャンバンドマンとして今も活動し
てるんですけど
この日高校生の頃からすごく憧れたアメリカのバンドが
日に来日する来日ツアーに僕の番フェンスが共演できることになりました
官能そうそう
終演後そのバンドのメンバーに実は高校生の頃からずっとキープパンです
これ絶対に伝えたかったせっかくアメリカアメリカから来ているわけです
僕は実際に
いった言葉は
i レッスンまで行ったところでアエリ進んだと過去形だからあとは聞いたんですよ
ずっと聞いてた本地生てくれておりますね
頭がパニックになって憧れの人もいる
いく形もありませんですよ
家に帰ってあまり付やすいからいえ勝ちあげましたん
僕がいいなかった英語は
ims 20 ur 人数
si 合わせる入っ
高校生の頃から音楽ずっと聴いてますこれが言えばならなかったです
もう
よく見てみたら全然難しくないですよね中学文法でもいけそう
こうやって冷静に考えたらでたはずのレースが僕は瞬時に口から出すことができなかっ
たわけです
逆に言うと
もしこのフレーズが瞬時に
出ていたら僕はその場における英語が話せる人にはなれたんです
外税語が話せるの体が描くなっ
それまでの自分は
一般的に言われているように教科書例のたくさんにしてました
でも実際の生活でその後歌手礼物かぶってを来なかったんですよ
三女じゃないんですけど you take 1時自分の言葉に入れ替えて言われて
くださいました
es tu
レースがありますすごく便利なプレーで
活性なのかしていん
これは教科書の通り新 step 5ファールポンフリーいう絵って覚えてますよん
実際に使う時は
is 中パーリーパワーをしたメディアですって言わなきゃいけなかったんですよこの
言い換えに実際が生じて言葉に詰まります
郊外ます
最初から
その方オリジナル英語フレーズに入れ帰った上でそのレイプを覚えた方がいいんじゃ
そこから僕は教科書の例文見えるために酒豪
愛になる目的公は自分のことに入る
数字があったら自分の数人はいるそんな感じで置き換えて自分オリジナルフェチを
フォンを覚えることからですよ
すると
オリジのレッグプレスを
英語として出した時に会話が成立してっていく実に気づいたん
英語が話せるというのはすぐに言えるオリジナルレイクプレイスの
引き出しが多いことだったんですよね
俺は素晴らしいるっていう
で僕の英語英語が話せれば強いが完全に決まりました
ん
英語が話せるとは
居間にいたい英語フレーズが
瞬時に出てくるのはある
海外留学しているとか外国人の街が多いかじゃなくて今に耐えるフレーズが瞬時に出て
くる人を僕は英語が話せる人と決めます
そして僕は
いつか自分が海外に住み始めたらどんなことを言いたくなるんだろう
その考えるところから始めました
いつか自分が言いそうなおり謝礼グレースって何だろう
2つの共通点があることに気づきます
一つは
日頃自分の身に起こること
例えばカナダアメリカに住み始めの時に幻想
友達ができます
何を話すんだろう
4仕事だったら週末何してるの
こんなこと多分話しましたよじゃない
それから日頃自分の身に起こる出来事を英語で言うようにしたらこういったためにすぐ
に答えがある
次日頃自分の頭で考えていること
よく日常会話ダイブでイエローなりたい聞こえると思うんですけど
日常会話って人によく絶対違うんですよ
例えばアクセラが多いと思うんですけど
大学生の日常会話は
何だろうな授業の範囲が触れるか心配だ
こんなことで1週間になります6一方で
子育てをしている着方とかは子育てを大変だけどすごく楽しくて
黒の一助くらいになりますよねね違う自分が自分の頭に日頃考えていることを英語で
言いようにしたり
なるほど
日頃自分の身に起こることと
日頃自分の仲間に考えるよ
をやってもしかして
日記じゃないかとっ
日記に書くぐらいパーソナルな出来事を全部英語で家にしていけば自分にとっての英語
が話せるを最短日で叶えられるんじゃないかっていう
分かった今日からエイム日記を書こう
それから今に至るまで5年間蔵庫前に生後でに着替える
英語リッジの習慣をとして払った夢が5つあります
一つ目がカナダライブツアー
最初に話したように僕は大日ダメリカからのラインスバンドこの
ツアーで自分が言いたい事を話さなかっ分ショックを受けて語勉強すれば
へついに数年越しに今度は台レンズですね僕が手なのでライブをする
今年も英語日記で覚えた自分の身の前にフレーズを披露するより喉を話しましただこれ
これが実際の写真ですこれめちゃくちゃ盛り上がりました
ん
黒密輸2番の狙うにアンコウできます
日本じゃを通った9回です com
やっぱり日本人は英語を話せないって
世界一世界的な共通認識があるんでその中で当時21です
羽立かな
こんなちっちゃい japanese ボーイがそれなりに美味い英語を話してるね
その事実に音楽いるもそのジェンズに賛同してくれたとってめちゃくちゃ盛り上がり
ます
次僕は学校にかような留学
これは英語に機能ってくなることができます
学校に通わない留学留学て学校に行くことじゃないと思うかもしれないんですけどいい
僕はもこの身体ツアーがあまりにも素晴らしい経験だったので
翌年から
バンドックスを休止して
福井教授の息子の立教大学も休学して
かなり過ぎはじめも5穴しまう
次なる目標
体でデザイナーとして制御ホテルこれに決めましたん
実はバンドグッズを作るためにデザインスキルが必要であの
同時期にデザインの独学も初めてます
これは最近がでいらっしゃるんですけど
その当時は自分のバッグ万物を作るくらいで区別これが仕事になくなかっ
でも体に入って
デザインスキルが仕事になったら
前年の花ツアーを超えるぐらいの素晴らしい姫丸キューじゃないかと思って
僕はカーデザイナーとして性器を持ってるこれだけ
処理を食べ出しません
当たり前ですけど
japanese 後は一人中にツボにいきなり仕事が舞い込んでくるわけありません
僕は
毎日カフェに行きます
英語力がまだまだ触れないことも住み始めてから気づいたので
まずはカフェ好きなカフェにチュールがって言って
前に最後連撃をかけました隣の必ずに a 1質問したりします
英語教えてもらって無料ですね6
コーヒーらーありますよねミドルぐらいですでもさっき人に語学力平均300万の人
じゃないか
本当に南部の卵別ぐらい
費用でほか学校に行かない留学での日気がしますん
こんな生活を結局1年がわからんですよなんですけどこんな生活を進めるにつれて
がカナダでデザイナーもして働くことができるようになります
かめ簿カフェの間に
全身自分でないしたグッズを着てアパレルストーリー
いくのを趣味にしてません
あるアパレルスターの中まあ死ぬんですけどから
すごいここ147年話しかけてくれ
僕は英語人気で覚えた自分の身の回りフレーズをガンガンに使ってこれが自分で財産だ
地盤英紙サンで今夢もてからにしてこんなことを彼に伝えます
だからすごく金くれてじゃあ用のグッズを家の明かり嘘で販売所
で僕の初めてのカードの仕事は自分のデザイングッズをカナダモントリオールが溢れる
ストで販売するところが私なりません
これだけじゃって請求は来ないんですよね
次に動かしたこと世界中のクラフト仕事をすることができました
様英語に気を使って
どういうことかというとそれまで勉強のために反した英語にいい
その日の日記の内容イメージタイヤストを変えて
毎日インスタグラムで発表し始めました
そのうち絶対にグラフィックデザイン科イラストレーションとか栄養の家具をつける
時間かかったんですけどちょっとずつ所つずつ世界中のいろんな企業が僕の英語にいい
ラップを見て仕事を好んでくれる
ました
お客さんしました
アメリカ人のアーティストたくさんあったらグッズデザインで知りカバージャケ
知りジャケットデザインが
あとは田んぼ苦労がプレールの youtube を全部デザイン
用法とかチャンネルの画像ぞ
また中国のホテルから
ロゴデザインを得ないと間に上る
イラストんを開いたと思います本当にいろんなすことが良い1持って良いん
を欠く中に入って少し目立った
デザイナーとして請求のてるお花よくやっています全部英語リ
最後
本を出版します
あの本です英語日記の本
ただ体生活が始まって1年ちょっとが過ぎたあたりでかなりいろんな知らなかったん
ですよ
しかもここがでからほとんど使ってないです英語日記燃料が素晴らしい
そして僕はカードでこうやって働くかな錦鶏を共に出して昔の自分の形として人に伝え
たい
思ってブログを始めましたさあそのプロが英語独学の検索ワードで google 1
位になりました
ついこのままで2年くらいずっと5
父がようなことがわかりますん
それがきっかけで左右書という出版社の方からお声かけをいただき
つい先週です1週間魔本を出版します
態度は台風が英語に規模いうまさしく英語日記を僕の人生を変えていく
今の僕がやりたいことそれは英語に息を
留学円債はスクールに続く第3の選択肢にしたいと思ってます
これまでは自分のようにお金がないけど英語話せるなりたい人絶対今もいると思うん
ですよ
確かにお金をかけていっ語学留学も素晴らしいと言うぞ
でもある程度まとまったお金がないとレゴが外れにならないんでしたっけ
思ってないですね僕は5年間の英語に着る習慣を通して語学習得とは
お金がなくて環境づくりによるものなんだって水
が英語に巨額習慣をつけたら本当に中でも話はなる
本線とねどうしても伝えたい米村自分にはないん
本渓伝えたなんかブログも始めた4本も書きます
を堪えんですよ明治さんとイラストレーター言うのは本格のネオンさえ乗った目 at
選手の話た本というです
いないが彼アンですし
もう着れねえこの考え方を伝えたいっ
お金がないとき僕はアイデアを使いますん
何が生まれる時のタコがアイデアを使おう
アイデアが常に優先 g の位置にあるか
もしかしたら1落ち続けちゃうかもしれないような何とか
ひきつになる感情とかそういうのが生まれないんです生まれたとしても間が一番上に
あるから相手に撮って帰ったらで解決しようかこれをずっと考え
それが僕のレンズにずっとあります
a 雰囲気の現場本当に素晴らしいとうんっ
ただ僕はこれが終わったら今日も抉り取っ
本当に貴重な機会で素晴らしい的だった ea 5 e が掛る
浴衣皆さん今日から5連休を書いてみませんか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]